on a de la boîte à bout car ce soir
alors et bien sûr ces sont les
chroniqueurs bien sûr qui donne des
infos sur les autres chroniques alors je
vous dira quand mathieu déjeunent au
restaurant ils essaient toujours de
négocier son repas gratuitement en
échange d'un poste à star c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce vrai nom mais pas de
commentaires c'est vrai j'ai une
technique à donner aux autres stars
autour des missions mais pour ceux qui
nous regardent peut-être chez tous à une
technique elle marche une fois sur cinq
camps l'addition arrive à venger sur
riesch 10e serveurs est-ce que je vous
dois quelque chose et parfois il est
tellement surpris par ma phrase shiloh
qui me dit rien ça arrive une fois sur
dix c'est à peu près à oued m'a dit ça
te dis maman va payer et je dirais même
sac à l'épée mais ça valait le prix
c'est sympa les deux maintien pour
l'émission du 1er mai matthieu delormeau
a demandé à tous les autres chroniqueurs
s'il était payé double après avoir eu sa
réponse il est tombé malade à 17 heures
jamieson ok mais je vous dis c'est 2 à
benjamin trouve que les émissions sans
mathieu sont meilleurs et trouve que les
audiences le prouve
ben y'a qu'à regarder les chiffres c'est
toi qui disais oui s'il a dit ça craint
il en est qu à 4-4 que bagages à main
avait dit ça valérie a exigé comme la
mariah carey de tunis à ce qu on
augmente le nombre de paquets de
rouleaux de réglisse dans son émission
ouais parce que tout nommé chroniqueur
adore les réglisses et moi aussi
d'accord à un cyril hanouna déjà dû
présenter des excuses
je connais pas à des collègues après
s'être introduits dans leur bureau en
leur absence
oui il ya les immunisés c'est quoi
l'histoire est finie c'est ta fais caca
et s'être mis leurs téléphones entre ses
fesses ignoble ça vous rappelle quelque
chose par titre le mc do that in your
head on ne comprend pas là et ça vous
rappelle quelque chose c'est quoi
l'histoire s'était pas erré j'ai fait
l'essai de production les grilles il y
avait un bureau avec des filles à côté
du vôtre
oui que vous aimiez pas trop si je sais
mes copines bassines et donc quand elles
sont partis de leur bureau
cette rentrée dans le bureau oui j'ai
pris le téléphone fixe non ils voulaient
me téléphone fixe sans l'effet que ça
téléphone ensuite comme j'étais mort de
rire je vous connais par coeur
il a téléphoné
[Rires]
anne on l'a compris que ça sentait donc
la merde
ces plans le saviez vous le rsv le
patron des réserves dans le bureau a
confié que vous avez mis votre téléphone
à son téléphone dans vos fesses
l'horizon à des remercier les téléphones
avec le vôtre
oui et il est content propre parade
alors parce qu'on s'amusait avec un
autre ami qui étaient là qui s'appelle
fabien voilà deux lettres et on faisait
exprès parce qu on rajoutait les trucs
comme ça